it's birthday season in my house
because the majority of us were born approximately
40 weeks after New Year's
which is suspicious
but maybe not surprising
and I'd love to know if this is a universal experience for mums
but no matter how much planning I seem to do
I always find myself up until about
midnight the night before
baking a fkn ridiculous cake
and the night before Olive’s 6th
birthday party was no exception
because my little darling requested
a “bright pink heart shaped glittery strawberry cake”
which definitely is in my repertoire and
definitely didn't leave me sweating
I made a fluffy vanilla sponge before
separating that out into two bowls
and using a gel baby pink food colouring to colour one half
then I layered the pink batter and the plain batter
and kind of swirled it with a knife
so hopefully we create a marble effect
I made two cakes like this
and drizzled them with a bit of simple syrup
to help keep them moist
before sandwiching them together with a
buttercream and strawberry jam filling
then I crumb coated it all
painted my nails and called it a night
the next morning I got started on a pink butter the cream
and I know the hard way what that
plastic guard thing is for
for my mixer
which I definitely should have been using
and will be using moving forward
layered all my pink frosting before smoothing
it out with a hot dough scraper
and I don't have a proper turntable
but what I do have is good old Kiwi ingenuity
so I just used a Lazy Susan that I keep my jars in in the pantry
and a cake board and it worked out aces
now I am far from proficient when it comes to cake decorating
but what I lack in talent I make out for with enthusiasm
I did a pretty average job on these rosettes if I'm honest
but when your target audience is a bunch of 6 year old girls
it doesn't really matter does it
a good sprinkle of edible glitter will hide all sins
and you can't convince me otherwise
Olive chose the pink glitter when we were at the shop recently
but then we decided it didn't really contrast well enough
so we opted for a silver
she requested fresh cut strawberries to top it all off
and candles obviously
now cowgirl Barbie
is gonna take this cake down to the farm
to have a party with all her little friends
is it a bit garrish?
absofuckinlutely
but is she over the moon?
I hope so cause I just about killed myself making it
this is how the marbling turned out
and it actually tasted pretty bloody good